more you got so many stories with the
ESPYs can you tell any of them are you
sworn to secrecy you are well you know
professional Kotov could you be okay
without naming names your fate who's the
worst presenter I'll name a name okay
dan Patrick oh you are so much trouble
oh my god how was like Trump uart you
don't remember I was this when I was
doing it with Bill Murray no I didn't do
the show that note was when you were
doing it with Keith and we had Josh
Charles and Peter Krause ax ya playin
you and I mean it was a poorly
thought-out idea i will grant wait we
had a couple of poorly thought out there
are poorly gets really thought out skit
um no is you and Keith yeah I was you in
Keith so I guess I can't blame you
totally you can if you don't know I
think they think that you know keith was
I have a couple voicemail saved of God
love him I told me young lover I told
the ken griffey story oh my god yeah
when he showed up at the ESPYs he wanted
to have all of his home runs edited
together gather yes all of them and it's
500 and some I think at the time he
wanted it for his mom and then he wanted
a suit well yeah that was at McMinn
night the night before the show we
weren't sure he was the all-star game
was in town that weekend so uh we had
done you know three days of trying to go
get him to convince him to come went to
the All Star Cafe used to exist and went
there and uh you know so i got a call at
midnight the night before and it was ken
griffey jr who said you know I need a
suit I don't have a suit I was like okay
does that mean I have to get your suit
he's like yeah so I said well alright
let me call you back so I didn't know
what to do you know so I called Howard
Katz and like woke him up and said
senior management mothership president
yeah here's the president what do i do
Ken Griffey junior needs a suit he's
like get i'ma see all right so I gave
him my credit card met him in that Lobby
the hotel was like here's my credit card
right yeah that night go get a suit
tomorrow and he had a nice suit well
yeah expensive one a very expensive one
I got the bill there were some other
things on the credit
card that I wasn't prepared for
restaurant visits or should we say
entertainment clubs in New York adult
entertainment maybe Wow or maybe not
maybe not maybe not could have in
McDonald's tougher dealing with the
athletes or celebrities at the ESPYs uh
well the athletes you know I think it's
people don't realize that you know for a
net to be an entertainer you probably
played to an empty room at some point
you know in your life and they also are
really big fans of the athletes so the
ones that come are really excited to be
there the athletes i dun like the Oscars
or the Emmys where you know winning one
actually helps your career the ESPYs
that wasn't the case yeah we really had
to build it into something that was a
night that the athletes valued that it
was something that you know now there
are athletes the ESPYs are in 25th year
coming up which I blows my mind so there
are athletes who have been you know
alive only when there's been an SP right
but that wasn't the case when we started
it and it was like come down to this
award show that we created and you've
never heard of before so it's been a
really slow building process but I
remember Bill Murray hosting an OC did
the opening number oh he didn't I did
you open another ok so we're behind
we're backstage the day before two days
before and it's just a group of people
so it's bill and his writers write and
this is before my time and John Walsh
yeah yeah the guy who created Sports
Center so John is there and I'm there
with Chris Myers and I mean so bill bill
said I want you guys in there so we're
talking idea here's one of the great
comedic minds of all time and he's
actually listening to us as we're trying
to help him with his opening skin
somebody fires up a joint oh so then it
starts getting past my boss is handing
me the joint John didn't smoke I didn't
either but he like I did you inhale that
oh I Saturday smoke absolutely but I'm
going I got my boss here Bill Murray and
bill didn't smoke either I guess some of
these writers that that's their creative
juice or something and I went
the SP sounds like it's gonna be a whole
lot of fun with Bill Murray oh I would
love to get Bill Murray back this year
with the Cubs I mean maybe it's the year
that he comes back right and present
them oh yeah team of the year well if
they win it's voted on by fairness it is
ideas believe me am I let my job would
be so much be easier you wanna there is
a cup there one story that is one of my
favorite stories and my favorite one of
my favorite presenters is Will Ferrell a
couple of years ago he we wanted him to
come out and accept as Tiger Woods do
you remember that came on stage well you
should look it up because it's very
funny he came out and accepted as tiger
woods and he was I'm tiger woods and
thanked all these sponsors and he made
up and that was same thing that you're
talking about literally he showed up and
said what am i doing and he was going on
in 10 minutes and I said I'd like you to
go out and accept his Tiger Woods it's
like all right and went downstairs and
came up with a whole bit in like five
minutes went out and it's one of the
best things he had 10 minutes to prepare
oh yeah completely did what am i doing
and then it's just magic suppose he's
awesome he could read the phone looking
he's uh he's will ferrell she's more
band the co-director and producer the
Ben Simmons documentary one and done
airs tonight on showtime at nine Eastern
cool approach to we were approached by
Ben and his family and what did you ask
for in access and honesty now was there
anything that was gonna be off limits uh
no I mean there were some limitations of
some of the basketball stuff at LSU that
you know we had but from been no we've
seen some headlines here and I don't
know if they're taken out of context i
did watch the documentary mm-hmm but Ben
rails on against the NC double-a saying
it's the NCAA they're effed up right now
is he referring to the one and done I
think or circle there are a couple
places where he reacts to the to the
system and the NC double-a and I think
what's important and hopefully people do
watch and and see it this our intention
for this documentary was to you know you
mentioned John Walsh and John Walsh is
in my head all the time find a journey
find a journey get access and discover
something and that's always the goal is
to be let in on a process that normally
well aren't letting on and this was a
very fascinating year in a young man's
life it was going to be pivotal one way
or the other and it wasn't just been
that was going to go through it it was
his family and so the access to that was
let's go through this from Ben's
perspective just so people know from
Australia yeah his dad was a basketball
player in Australia then he goes to last
year in high school not burden milk yes
great school in he went play for Kevin
Boyle who's you know coached a number of
number one picks in the last ten years
and he goes to Ellis goes down his
Godfather is david patrick one of the
assistant assistant head coach there
yeah yes so so in being in that journey
and being in the moment as much as we
could we were there when been
experienced frustration so the times
when he's which are reading about now
and I seen a lot of the headlines where
he's you know the F word is one you
can't fly saying on TV though I won't um
uh you know it's gonna get a headline
but that was a very much in the moment
reaction to something that you know he
was doing at the moment so that was
against the NCAA and certain regulations
that he was limited to whether that be
who could buy him a meal or you know
he'd be running out of money you know
going to Walmart to buy something and
it's that juxtaposition that he's not
allowed to take a pair of shoes and the
family has to keep track of receipts
while at the same time he's passing his
jersey being sold or a billboard that
saying you know LSU number 25 did he not
have friends there's there's did have
friend that was a very unfortunate
headline in a story he had great friends
on the team again was not a focus that
we did was it's not a story about LSU
but he had great roommates great friends
what he was saying again in a moment was
that they're in the position that you're
in you look at someone who's on TV on
sports center or in any position and you
think god that's the life but
everything's perfect well no they go
through the same things and sometimes
more magnified than anyone else does and
for Ben I think this year really was the
past year was one where he realized like
okay I have to be careful who I open up
to and who I trust now Darcy one of his
roommates he's known for a long time and
Keith like a
and two great guys that are great
friends so that headline was really not
not exactly I think and you got a lot of
conversations where there's skyping
going on with him and his sister who's
very influential in his career you get
you get some you know really good
moments there I don't know if there's
teaching moments where we say lets the
NCAA and the NBA need to look at the
one-and-done or LSU I don't know if they
indict themselves with how he was not a
student their second semester for the
most part hey I'm gonna get a 18 that's
all I need to get stay eligible he got
suspended for one game because he missed
a class I don't even know minutes yeah I
don't even know if he went to class
second semester I don't know if he had
to go to class second semester that was
the one question I had with is the one
and done is really embarrassing
universities or they embarrass
themselves with this and I don't know if
this helps springboard a conversation
which is why I wanted to have you on I
thought it was that important with the
one and done where are we headed with
this and is there another way that we
can get kids to college maybe they stay
two years or if you don't want to go to
college you don't go to college well I
mean it's interesting you saw the
president the NCAA come out and say that
he thinks that there's rules that need
to be improved and that this is really
the one and done is not an NCAA rule
it's an NBA rules um I I hope it starts
a conversation but I hope any film or
any story starts a conversation we know
personally in being able to observe the
little bit that we did I think I think
that you know there could be things that
are done if to help prepare any student
let's say for what their goal is if i go
into college and my goal is to become an
accountant well i'm going to take
certain classes that helped me prepare
for that Ben Simmons went into school to
become an NBA player everyone like
that's what do you want into school from
and in the documentary i think there's
clips from your show or that's what
people were saying maybe there are
things for those athletes why don't have
classes that are catered yeah if that's
your major you major in it money
management real estate Nick picking it
all of that if you're going in the
marketing PR and nobody can blame you
can't blame anybody if you get out and
then you don't have a career and you
don't have a degree you majored in your
one and done and this would maybe get
those kids to stay and actually complete
one year in God
think that look there's there is there's
two sides of the story as well you know
I mean to the argument as well if if if
you're saying I'm going to school for a
year then you know there you have to
live up to whatever that side of the
contract has been did look into what the
rules were that he had to oblige by and
did you know and realize it okay I have
to get this grade point average in the
first semester and I'm eligible and he
did so but yeah do I think there could
have been classes that he would have
been probably found more value in then
maybe oceanography or the class that he
missed which was how to study for
college that was the class he missed
yeah well by the way will ferrell says
say hi to Maura for me ah hello ask her
how mad he has been got when I did Harry
Carey I got a first SP yes sir that was
my ally Olivet was painful I it was one
of those so awkwardly funny oh right
yeah you did a great job on this okay
you should be proud on the dock yeah you
do or on this interview you did both
yeah I got a little feral to email you
yeah you did no yeah that more man's the
co-director producer Ben Simmons
documentary one-and-done airs tonight on
showtime at nine eastern and pacific I
think it's must-see TV great see ya
thank you funny after the hour right
here on the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience